David Boder: [In English] Geneva, August the 26th. Geneva, August the 26th, 1946, at the ORT School. The interviewee is a young man, Sigmund Reich.
David Boder: [In German] Wie alt sind Sie?
Sigmund Reich: [In Yiddish] айк бйп цееарцйв йашт
David Boder: [In English] Twenty years old. He made his way through various concentration camps, then to Switzerland and the ORT Schools.
David Boder: [In German] Also, Herr Reich sagen Sie mir nochmal was ist Ihr voller Namen und wie alt sind Sie? Sprechen Sie Jiddisch.
Sigmund Reich: [In Yiddish] йа, айк чарт [чап] ... [аеочмаш?] ййгйщ штгп.
David Boder: [In English] Yes.
Sigmund Reich: [In Yiddish] айк бйп... айк бйп... айк бйп аййрвтбейшп айп тсишййк
David Boder: айп тсишййк йа, [аеочмаш?]
Sigmund Reich: абтш айп тсишййк бйп айк рйщи марв втеетжп - айп варцп а йаш аеп а дамб.
David Boder: йаИ?
Sigmund Reich: айк бйп [ар?]втфашп ч’[ййп] бтмвйт - гаши жтртп о’ втеетп 6 йаш. гтп, жтртп о’ втфашп ч’[ййп] феймп.
David Boder: йаИ.
Sigmund Reich: айп феймп бйп айк втеетп бйж це гй чшйв - втеетп 7 йаш - бйж це гй йтцийвт [айцийвт] чшйв.
Sigmund Reich: айп арфарв чшйв бйп айк чшарч втееашп.
David Boder: айп еетмлтшайп еетмлтш Stadt in Polen sind Sie втеетп?
Sigmund Reich: айп чшечт [чшачт].
David Boder: Wie?
David Boder: чшечт?
Sigmund Reich: йа - Krakow - аейу феймйщ.
David Boder: [In German] In Krakow. Un dortn haben Sie gelebt [?], yes? Nu?
Sigmund Reich: [In Yiddish] йа, айк бйп гаши втеетп ойи гй оаот, иаит... даи втварвтп тфтс а... [аеочмаш?] чшалп - а гас даи втмажи с’чйрг - аж, аж, ойи амт, амт, амт отртш - ййгйщ отртш феп 81 бйж 44 еети отп ртотп це цееарвс-ашбти.
David Boder: ре?
Sigmund Reich: ре - айж тш - аж айк оййп аж тш айж аеетчвтфашп ч’[ййп] мтобтшв
David Boder: йаИ. ре?
Sigmund Reich: бйп айк амййп втеетп ойи гй оаот...
David Boder: [аеочмаш]
Sigmund Reich: л’аб фашщйгрс. л’аб вташбти фаш а щрййгтш, л’аб вташбти бйй... айк даб втишавп тотцтрс[?] фтчмтк, л’аб вташбти айп а втщтфи аййп оам... гас ееас айк жав; айк даб вташбти бйй а щрййгтш, жтп... о’даи жйк аффашгйри еей а оам [?] а фаш вшащп.
David Boder: ре, вййи ееййитш!
Sigmund Reich: фаш ойш... [аеочмаш?] айп иейжри рййп дергтши фтшцйв айж втбейтши втееашп гас втиа айп чшечт [чшачт].
David Boder: айп чшачт?
Sigmund Reich: айп чшачт.
David Boder: йаИ.
Sigmund Reich: о’даи ausgesiedelt гас варцт - гй варцт - амт ййгп феп чшечт [чшачт] ‘аи [даи] о’ [отп] втжйгми ч’[ййп] Podgorze, цееййит иййм. с’дййси ажей... о’[д]аи...
David Boder: [аеочмаш]
Sigmund Reich: а ск даи от’ аейсвтеейжп.
David Boder: йаИ?
Sigmund Reich: раш с’айж гаши рак втбмйбп тимтлт ц... - ажей еей 000,03 отрищп. гй штщи даи от’ аейсвтеейжп. айк бйп аейлти аейсвтеейжп втееашп. айж втеетп... айж втеетп ойи оййп оаот, с’айж втеетп... даб ойк втдаи гаши а вшасоеитш [Grossmutter] ойи а вшасфаитш [Grossvater]. аергж жтртп втеетп аейсвтеейжп. оййп... [аеочмаш?] даи от’ втфашп ч’[ййп] иашраее, [Tarnow] аеп айк бйп втфашп 23 чймаотитш феп... феп Tarnow - Radomysl Wielki.
David Boder: амййп?
Sigmund Reich: айк ойи гй оаот.
David Boder: ойи гй оаот. ре?
Sigmund Reich: о’даи гаши втфашп аеп втеетп гаши бйй гй оаотс втщеейситш. гаши... гаши... гаши даб айк втоежи ашбтип...
David Boder: аеп еее айж гй иаит втеетп?
Sigmund Reich: оййп иаит айж втеетп айп мтобтшв. [Lemberg] ажей еей - айж бйж гй шесйщт чшйв...
David Boder: йаИ.
Sigmund Reich: щфтитш, [айк даб] йтци [айци] бачеотп феп ап арчм [uncle] феп бтмвйт [Belgium] а бшйее аж мтцит рали даи тш ойк... даи ап арчм ... [аеочмаш?] феп   Dombrov [Dombrau in Germ., Dabrowa in Pol.] аеп отш ееййс айк рйщи.
David Boder: абтш Dombrov айж гак шесмарг?
Sigmund Reich: шесмарг.
David Boder: аеп отш ееййсие рйщи?
Sigmund Reich: отш ееййс айк рйщи.
David Boder: ре? амжа?
Sigmund Reich: аергж дабп о’[йш] втщйчи ч’[ййп] Radomysl аеп гаши дабп о’[йш] втчшйвп а фаш бшйее
David Boder: феп еетотп?
Sigmund Reich: феп иаип.
David Boder: йаИ.
Sigmund Reich: аеп аейу гтн, айж щфтитш аейсвтбшалп гй шесйщт чшйв, еей аейк с’айж аейсвтбшалп, дабп гй гййищп втвтбп а бафйймт [бафтм]: аейу феп йтгт фаоймйт оеж жйк аййп оап щитмп [г]тшойи чартп [г]тшойи рак бмййбп. аеп айк даб ажей втийтп [втиап]...
David Boder: еей ами жййи айш втеетп?
Sigmund Reich: 13 - втеетп 13 йаш.
David Boder: йаИ.
Sigmund Reich: аеп ажей даб айк втийтп [втиап]. л’аб втееами гй оаот жам бмййбп гаши. ре, айп щитим...
David Boder: йаИ?
Sigmund Reich: бйп айк втварвтп аеп л’аб ойк арвтоамгп - л’аб ойк арвтоамгп аеп с’лоти аф. чап ойк рйщи тшйртшп [erinnern] ееас фаш а иав гас айж втеетп...
David Boder: гас айж рйи еейлийв.
Sigmund Reich: бйп айк... [аеочмаш?] айп чарцтришацйарс... [Konzentrations...] айп мавтш. втдййсп йтгт гшйй ееалп еети отп чартп адййофашп. аеп оййрс... цеейй ееалп агешлвййтп, даи аейсвтжйгми гас варцт щитим
David Boder: йаИ?
Sigmund Reich: феп гтоемс [гтоами] даб айк щейп бтдейфи рйщи чййп арерв - рйщи феп гй оаот, рйщи феп чййртн.
David Boder: еей ге? айш жййи втварвтп ц’ гтш ашбти?
Sigmund Reich: шйййк: йа. аеп о’аи втжави айп а мавтш - айп а цееййи щитим ашййп.
David Boder: йаИ.
Sigmund Reich: о’аи втжави аж йтгт гшйй ееалп о’тмп [ойш еетмп] дабп фшйй.
David Boder: ре?
Sigmund Reich: ... [аеочмаш?] с’айж бмейж втеетп гаши цеейй ееалп, даи отп аейс... аейс гас варцт щитим аейсвтжйгми.
Sigmund Reich: о’аи жйй втщйчи - фашщйчи... с’айж рйщиа ч’[ййп] рзъ [?] феп жйй айбтш дейфи.
David Boder: йаИ.
Sigmund Reich: бтдейфи, феп гтн чацти[?] аейк айж рйщиа ч’[ййп] рзъ [?].
Sigmund Reich: щфтитш бйп айк втчеотп - с’айж иачт втеетп Mielec гаши, гаши вташбти... [аеочмаш?] ойи фмевцййв еетшч ... [аеочмаш?].
David Boder: йаИ?
Sigmund Reich: гаши вташбти...
David Boder: аеп феп гтш оеитш, даи айш рйи втдтши?
Sigmund Reich: вашрйщи.
David Boder: даи жйк рак гтн втдтши тфтс феп гтш оеитш?
Sigmund Reich: рййп, вашрйщи
David Boder: вашрйщи, ре?
Sigmund Reich: о’аи жйк втвтбп ап тцд... о’аи а оам а чашиафм це вт... це вт... - о’аи втврбти аейк чашиафм... аргтшт жалп... [аеочмаш?] це дамип а щийчм рщод.
David Boder: дн.
Sigmund Reich: ажей дабп о’ фашбштрви цеейй йаш. аеп рак гй цеейй йаш, ажей еей гй шесп дабп жйк арвтдейбп ц’ ртритшп - с’дабп жйк втртритши ц’ шййщт - [Rszeszow] даи от’ аергж тееачеайши, аергж тееачеайши ч’[ййп] гййищмарг. жтртп о’ втфашп nach Auschwitz ... [аеочмаш?] аеп nach Plaszow; ‘абп о’ втоййри аж... [аеочмаш?] га айж щейп га а мавтш.
David Boder: еей марв жйри айш втеетп айп Auschwitz?
Sigmund Reich: айп Auschwitz ... [аеочмаИш] гаши жтртп о’аейсвтщиартп раш а фаш щтд. аейу гй ееавартп
David Boder: йаИ. [аеочмаИш]
Sigmund Reich: гтп, жтртп о’ ееййитш втфашп.
David Boder: йаИ?
Sigmund Reich: жтртп о’ втфа[шп]...
David Boder: еетш жййи тх втеетжп - отртш... отртш, фшейтп?
Sigmund Reich: бмейж отртш. с’айж втеетп тфтс дергтши фшейтп аеп о’аи ж’ - гали жйк о’ - айп Auschwitz даи о’ жйй аеетчвтреотп.
David Boder: аеп амт жтртп втеетп бмейж отртш?
Sigmund Reich: бмейж отртш.
David Boder: еей фйм отртш айп а ееавап?
Sigmund Reich: айп а ееавап даи втчари жййп 80-90 отртш.
David Boder: даи отп аййк ашейсвтмажи це - аейб от’ даи втгашфи ашейсвййп?
Sigmund Reich: рййп, рйщи фйм отрищп, тфтс... аййп оам айп иав, цеейй оам айп иав дабп жйй аергж ашейсвтмажи.
David Boder: айш жййи йтци [айци] all [?] втеетп айп ашбййис-чшафи?
Sigmund Reich: ашбййис-чшафи... айй... с’дабп втжави гас, аж аергж даи аейсвтфагтши [cognate of Germ. “auffordern” = to demand or request] гй Heinkel - гй фмевцййв еетшч.
David Boder: а, гй Heinkel фмевцййв еетшч?
Sigmund Reich: йаИ.
David Boder: ре?
Sigmund Reich: [д]аи аергж аейсвтфагтши фаш гййищмарг, [ееййм о’аи] втеетп веит ашбййитшс. дабп ж’ аергж... жтртп о’ втфашп ч’ гййищмарг аеп втчеотп ч’ фмасбтшв, [Flossenburg] 6 чймаотитш феп сегти - tschechisch-sudetische, eh ...[аеочмаш?] вштртх. гаши - гаши айж втеетп аййрт феп гй тшвсит мавтшс. а мавтш феп гй гшйит - гшйит чмас. [гаши айж втеетп]... [аеочмаш?] бмейж фашбштлтшс - гййищт фашбштлтшс. гаши жтртп втчеотп шесп, феп фашщйгрт [фашщййгтрт] рацйартмтп, аеп г’[ас] амх айж втщйчи втееашп айп мавтш гаши. айп мавтш бйп айк гаши аейк - бйп айк аейк втеетп а - а лоти а - лоти а йаш - рйщи чййп варх йаш. щфтитш, гй шесп ‘абп жйк гаши втртритши - ‘аи о’ аергж аейсвтжйгми. гаши, айж аейк втеетп а фмевцййв еетшч феп Messerschnitt ...
David Boder: йаИ?
Sigmund Reich: гаши ‘[аи] аергж - ‘аи о’ аергж втфйши ч’ Kamienec - тфтс а 007 оап. айп Kamienec айж втеетп жййтш - с’айж втеетп щейп - айж втеетп щейп жййтш щмтли. с’айж втеетп а Kommando феп вшас шажтп [Gross Rosen].
David Boder: феп еетмлтш?
Sigmund Reich: вшас шажтп [Gross Rosen].
David Boder: йаИ?
Sigmund Reich: гтш Kommando фйштш айж втеетп а жййтш жййтш щмт...
David Boder: втеетп а жййтш щмтлитш отрищ.
Sigmund Reich: йаИ.
David Boder: еей марв [дасие] гашип втмтби?
Sigmund Reich: еейй! о’аи... феп арфарв бйп айк втеетп аф... [?] аейу отшсит ашбти... гаши втеетп еей а отларйч [mechanic]бйй оащйрт - вташбти бйй гшйй - щфтитш, ‘аи о’ - о’аи щейп втжтп аж гй шесп жтртп щейп ртри [ратри], ‘аи о’ гаши гй ашбти щейп афвтмажи - о’аи щейп рйщи вташбти гаши. о’аи аергж втщйчи - eh -аейу - с’втеетп [?] еейритш гтоемс [гтоами], ‘аи отп аергж арвтдейбп це щйчп - башачп це цтшййсп [?]. дамцтрт дййжтш ееас [о’] дабп втбейтши гашип. с’айж втеетп [?] а мавтш ц’ ееас... [аеочмаш?] жйй ‘абп втдййси тс цтртотп.
David Boder: ц’ фараргтш[?] це ртотп?
Sigmund Reich: йаИ.
David Boder: ееас даи от’ втоали ойи гй дамх?
Sigmund Reich: ойип дамх? о’аи афвтмййви аеп о’аи ж’ - о’аи тс втоежи ишавп - афщш а дамбп чймаотитш бйж - бйж це - це гтн фмах еее о’ мййви тс аф. аеп гаши айж втчеотп а аейиа, о’аи ж’ втоежи щфтчмтп[?] аейу а аейиа.
David Boder: йаИ? ре?
Sigmund Reich: тсп гаши айж втеетп жййтш - жййтш, жййтш щмтли. с’втеетп шййп ееастш.
David Boder: йаИ?
Sigmund Reich: айбтш дейфи - айп амт мавтшс айж втеетп тшщи [?], абтш гаши айж рак тшвтш еей гй айп фашап. гаши айж втеетп шййп ееастш. о’аи втвтбп гаши ап алим бшейи. аейу гтн - ажей даи о’ втмтби а варцп иав. о’аи втмтвп аейу щишей. гй щишей айж втеетп айп варцп фашоаитши. с’втеетп фйм ойси айп гтн. аййртш - с’аи щейп чййртн рйщи ашййрвтмййви. мтцирс, о’аи втгашфи тееачеайшп гй мавтш, ‘аи о’ а ск - а ск отрищп жтртп фтшрйлити гаши. аеп мтцирс айж чшарч втееашп аейлти а ск. ажей, феп гй варцт айж втеетп тфтс иейжри фйру - eh - иейжри фйру - фйру дергтши оап - ц’ еей [?] фйм. с’айж айп варцп втбмйбп 6, агтш, агтш, агтш 6 фефцйч - агтш 6 дергтши фефцйч отрищп.
David Boder: ееас дйййси, о’даи ж’ фтшрйли?
Sigmund Reich: о’аи ж’ - о’аи ж’ втайрви гаши, гаши даи о’ ж’ втайрви
David Boder: ееас дййси о’аи ж’ втайрви?
Sigmund Reich: о’аи ж’ аййрщийфтши втоали, аййрщфшйцервтп
David Boder: [In English] Yes.
David Boder: [In Yiddish] аеп ееас айж гтп втщтп?
Sigmund Reich: ... [аеочмаш?] айп... [аеочмаш?] а фаш щтд аййрщфшйцервтп. 6 щтд айж тш втмйвп. гтш отрищ айж втеетп иейи.
David Boder: айп еетмлп мавтш айж гас втеетп?
Sigmund Reich: Kamenz.
David Boder: Kamenz?
Sigmund Reich: гас айж мтбп Dresden.
David Boder: мтбп Dresden... еей даи отп гас вт... [?] - Kamenz?
Sigmund Reich: Kamenz. K-A-M-E-N-Z.
David Boder: E-N...?
Sigmund Reich: Z.
David Boder: Kamenz?
Sigmund Reich: йа, йа.
David Boder: еей даи - даи отп гас аййк втвтбп а аййрщфшйцерв?
Sigmund Reich: рйщи аергж. аергж - о’аи, о’аи вт... вт... гй ееас ‘абп втжтп гй отрищп чартп рйщи, чартп рйщи - жтртп щейп рйщи - с’[ее]тмп чййп оам рйщи ашейсдамип...
David Boder: ееас айж гтш Namen феп гтш отрищ ееас еетши жййтш щееак?
Sigmund Reich: с’жтртп чшарч.
David Boder: айш даи рйщи втдаи а сфтцйтмп раотп феп гтн?
Sigmund Reich: рййп.
David Boder: ееас айж втеетжп а оесмоап - Muselmann - даи айш втдтши?
Sigmund Reich: оесмоап - Muselmann - гас айж втеетп отрищп ееас жтртп варх чшарч втеетп.
David Boder: ре?
Sigmund Reich: отрищп ееас дабп щейп рйщи втчари вййтп...
David Boder: So, ееас дабп о’ втиап? о’ ‘аи втоали...
Sigmund Reich: о’аи ж’... о’ - рййп, айп мавтш - ‘аи о’ ж’ втайрви фаш цеейй ееалп[?]. аргтшт, о’аи оашвп фашеетргти.
David Boder: аЗдаЗ.
Sigmund Reich: гаши, еее айк бйп втеетп, айп гтн Kamienec, ‘аи о’ вт... втвтбп... аж йтгтш жам жтп аж... [аеочмаш?]
David Boder: даи отп жйй ашййрвтфйши айп штеейш, Revier ц’ ееас?
Sigmund Reich: айп штеейш ашййп даи, о’... айж, о’ ашейу аейфп цееййит щиач... о’аи гйк ашййрвтшефп аеп о’аи - о’аи отрищп втайрви, аеп рак фйру, жтчс щтд, жтртп - жтртп втеетп иейи.
David Boder: даи отп втеееси ееас гас айж?
Sigmund Reich: о’... гй отрищп дабп рйщи втеееси. абтш щфтитш, гй... щфтитш жтртп амтотп втжтп аж ж’ чеотп рйщи отш ашаф, аеп а оам ‘аи от’ втишави аййртн ашаф, ееас о’аи втеееси айж ашейфвтварвтп. ‘аи о’ втеееси аж аейб о’ шефи ж’ гаши, с’ иеи ж’...
David Boder: аеп ееас даи от’ гашип втиап ойи гй иййип [иейип]?
Sigmund Reich: ойи гй иейит? о’аи ж... с’вт[втб]п а - а чтсм ееас о’аи втдаи цен саотм-дййцерв [?] [Sammelheizung].
David Boder: ееас фаш а чтсм жави айш?
Sigmund Reich: ееас - ееас о’аи цен саотм-дййцерв. ееастш с’ гаши с’ а жак ееас даи... [аеочмаш?]
David Boder: йа.
Sigmund Reich: ажа жак - о’аи тс аеритшвтдййцп, аеп о’аи ашййрвтееашфп гй отрищп гаши, аеп ж’ фашбштри. аййп оам айж тс втеетп а фабшйч феп щиач... [аеочмаш?] л’ееййс рйщи втрей феп ееас, аеп гй фабшйч айж... гй фабшйч даи... даи о’ мйчеейгйши. айп гй фабшйч даи о’ашййрвт... аергж ашййрвтщйчи, аеп гаши втеетп а - аейк а 4,5 оараи, аеп еетп гй шесп жтртп ртри втчеотп, ‘аи о’ аергж тееачеайши - жтртп о’ втфашп а фтшцп иав. о’аи рйщи ашййр... о’аи аергж рйщи втвтбп афйме ч’ бйсм ееастш.
David Boder: ре, аеп еее жййи айш гтп втфашп?
Sigmund Reich: гаши жтртп о’ втфашп ч’ - ч’ Dachau щейп.
David Boder: ре, ееас war втчеотп фаш айп Dachau?
Sigmund Reich: айп Dachau - айп Dachau бйп айк щейп втеетп айп варцп щееак. гаши, ‘аи о’ щейп рйщи вташбти. аергж жтртп щейп втеетп ажей еей Musselmen - аейб о’ чтп жавп - жтртп щейп втеетп - амт. гас варцп - втеетп а фаш... [аеочмаш?] аййрцйвт отрищп жтртп - жтртп рак втеетп втжери.
David Boder: ре?
Sigmund Reich: аеп гй аййрцйвт ееас жтртп втеетп втжери - о’аи ж’ аеетчвтщйчи ойи а ишарсфаши, фаш - фаш мтцирс дабп - дабп гй аотшйчартш жййтш щмтли втбаобашгйши гаши. Munchen... гй варцт аеовтври.
Sigmund Reich: абтш йтгп - о’аи втеееси амт оам, аж аййрцт бйй рали, цеетмтеет бйй рали, чеотп гй аотшйчартш, аеп ж’ баобашгйшп гаши гй втври.
David Boder: ре?
Sigmund Reich: ж’ ‘абп immer втееашфи - ж’ жтртп ашйбтшвтфашп айбтш аергжтш мавтш - ж’ ‘абп immer втееашфп гй щййр... - eh - шачтип, ееас с’абп бамейлитши...
David Boder: йа?
Sigmund Reich: аеп ажей с’жамп еейсп - жйй ‘абп втжтп ееас иеи жйк аейфп - аейу г’ тшг. ж’ ‘абп втеееси еее г’ мавтш айж.
David Boder: аЗдаЗ.
Sigmund Reich: г’ мавтш айж чййп оам рйщи втееашп втбаобашгйши.
David Boder: гтш мавтш айж рйщи втееашп баобашгйши?
Sigmund Reich: рййп, чййп оам рйщи.
David Boder: ре?
Sigmund Reich: аеп, ажей еей с’даи жйй immer - immer втеетп ееас а оам щмтлитш, гй аотшйчартш жтртп ртритш втееашп. о’ жтртп втеетп 2 иейжри ййгп... амт 2 иейжри дабп рйщи втчари вййтп. раш с’айж втеетп айп варцп - eh - иейжри жтчс дергтши оап.
David Boder: йа?
Sigmund Reich: гй жтртп втеетп фтйч рак це вййп. рйщи амт ‘абп... гй штщи жтртп щейп втеетп ажей чшарч. ж’ ‘абп втдаи втщееамтрт фйс, а’ рйщи ж’ жтртп айп варцп втеетп втщееамп. [жтртп] втеетп ажей арвтщееали... [аеочмаш?]
David Boder: ре?
Sigmund Reich: аергж даи о’ втоали - о’аи втоали а афтм [Appell], о’аи амт ййгп айп Dachau - амт ййгп ‘аи о’ цежаотп втшефп - ‘аи жйк ашейсвтшефп гй амт ртотп. фйш аеп цееарцйчсит айж втеетп гй тшщит Appell. фйру аеп цееарцйчсит ‘аи аергж рак а оам цежаотп втшефп, аеп г’ жйбп аеп цееарцйчсип, айп г’ фшй - ‘аи о’ аергж аейфвтеетчи жййтш фшй - фйртеет а жййвтш. о’аи аергж аейфвтщитми мейи шййтп аеп о’аи - о’аи аергж втфйши ц’ - ц’ гй ееавартп.
David Boder: йа?
Sigmund Reich: о’аи аергж щфтитш втфйши ц’ гй ееавартп. о’аи аергж втфйши - с’ееавап - йтгп ееавап warвтеетп дергтши оап. ж’ ‘абп рйщи - ж’ ‘абп рйщи втдаи ч’ маси - ч’ маси ееавап, ‘абп ж’ аергж втвтбп а дамб мййийщ ееавартс... [аеочмаш?] рйщи, ажей аж о’аи - аж о’аи чейн втчари щиййп. аеп жтртп о’ - ажей жтртп о’ арвтфашп - бйж - бйж а втеейст сиацйап айп тсишййк. гаши, айж втеетп - гй щишйч [айж] втеетп цтшйсп. ‘абп о’ втоеси ашервййтп [ашафвййтп] [?].
Sigmund Reich: жтртп о’ ашафвтварвтп - ж’ ‘абп аергж втжави аж о’ти оежп вййп 20 чймаотитш цен... [аеочмаш?] сиацйап, аеп гашойи [гтшойи], о’жам чартп ееййитш фашп. ажей еей жйй - жйй ‘абп гас... [аеочмаш?] цешйч, ‘абп жйй аергж втдййсп вййтп. жтртп о’ втварвтп 6 чймаотитш. [с’аи] арвтдейбп ц’ щрййтп. с’айж щейп втееашп иерчм. с’айж гтоамс [гтоами] втеетп еейритш. ж’ ‘абп арвтдейбп ц’ ар - ар - арцечееашийшп бйй гй фейтшйн гашип, втдамип гй щишей - гй амт жалп ажтмлт, аеп аергж гаши аййрфасп [?]. аергжтш ееавап айж ферчи втеетп гй мтцит... [аеочмаш?] чееашийшерв. ‘аи о’ аергж втжави йтгп - о’аи втжтп жтмртш - а фаш - аж йтгтш жтмртш жам жйк ртотп а фаш оап, аеп тш жам вййп жафаш - о’жам вййп - тш жам желп чееашийштп. ре, ‘абп о’ - аергж ‘абп ойи аергж аейк... [аеочмаш?] втдаи жтмртшс, аеп гаши айж втеетп тфтс а рййп - ц’ рййп оап. аеп о’ - аергж жтртп о’ втварвтп. ажей еей тш айж ашейфвтварвтп желп чееашийштп, ‘абп аергж - жтртп о’ аергж аеетчвтварвтп. аеп ажей ‘абп о’ втееаргтши - бйж о’ жтртп втчеотп ц’ щееййх. ре, о’айж втварвтп афщш 5, 6 чймаотитш, аеп о’ - ‘аи о’ втишафп гаши а...
David Boder: а оаотри. еетп жйри жй аеетч - hatten Sie sich separiert? Eh - еетп жйри жй аеетчвтмейфп?
Sigmund Reich: аергж жтртп о’ аеетчвтмейфп... [гтн] али аеп цееарцйчнип, рййп аеп цееарцйчнип.
David Boder: еей фйм жййи тх аеетчвтмейфп?
Sigmund Reich: 9 оап.
David Boder: 9 оап?
Sigmund Reich: йа.
David Boder: аеп айш даи тс втчтри вййп гешк гййищмарг?
Sigmund Reich: аергж ‘абп о’ вт... - аергж ‘абп о’ втдаи а аейсшййгт [Ausrede], аж гй шейит чшейх ‘аи аергж аейсвтфагтши. о’аи втдаи а аейсшййг, аж г’ шейит чшейх ‘аи аергж аейсвтфагтши. о’аи втдаи ажейрт фтчмтк... с’втеетп цйваштип, uh, бйсчеейи, гас айж втеетп с’варх...
David Boder: амжа, ееаши. еетп жйри тх це мтци втеетп ойи гй гййищп айп Dachau?
Sigmund Reich: айп Dachau. гтн 27сит жтртп о’ ашейсвтфашп.
David Boder: ре, аеп гтп?
Sigmund Reich: аергж жтртп о’ втфашп - афщш а иав агтш цеейй. гас чтп айк рйщи втрей жавп.
David Boder: ре?
Sigmund Reich: аеп щфтитш, ‘абп о’ рйщи втчари ееййитш фашп, фаш гй щфеш айж втеетп цтшйсп.
David Boder: [In English] Yes?
Sigmund Reich: [In Yiddish] аеп uh, о’аи - с’айж втеетп цтшйсп, ‘аи о’ втоежи ашафщиййп феп цев.
David Boder: йа?
Sigmund Reich: аеп о’аи втоежи аше... о’аи втоежи вййп ееййитш - рак 02 чймаотитш, а о’жам...
Sigmund Reich: о’ жтртп - о’ бмейж втварвтп 6 чймаотитш. с’втееашп рали. с’аи арвтдейбп ц’ - с’аи втщрййи. с’втеетп еейритш. аергж жтртп о’ - ‘аи о’ аергж арвтдейбп ц’ арцечееашийшп бйй гй фейтшйн гашип.
David Boder: фейтшйн?
Sigmund Reich: йа.
David Boder: ре?
Sigmund Reich: о’аи - гаши, еее гй щау айж - гаши, еее о’ дами г’ щишей.
David Boder: [In German] Ja. Ihr war pol[n]ische Häftling?
Sigmund Reich: [In Yiddish] ... еей... еей ажей...
David Boder: йа.
Sigmund Reich: פאליטישע העפטלינג ] Häftling]. אלע יידן זענען געטראגן אבצייכענס [Abzeichnen], ווי פאליטיש.
David Boder: ре?
Sigmund Reich: айп - айп - айп аергжтш ееавап, даи аейсвтфтми еейрцйв чееашийшерв.
David Boder: йа?
Sigmund Reich: даи айш втжави г’ Kommandofuehrer, аж йтгтш жтмртш жам жйк ртотп гаши а - а - а жтчс, жйбп бйж 01 оап, жам вййп желп тфтс а...
David Boder: [аеочмаИш]
Sigmund Reich: йа. жам вййп желп тфтс аейу рали ц’ щмафп.
David Boder: ре?
Sigmund Reich: айж ойи аергж втварвтп - ‘аи о’ - ‘аи о’ аергж втдаи аейк а жтмртш ееас айж втварвтп ойи аергж, тш айж ашейфвтварвтп желп еетвп - еетвп а рали втмтвтш. жтртп о’ аергж аеетчвтварвтп.
David Boder: жййи тх аеетчвтмейфп.
Sigmund Reich: жтртп о’ аергж аеетчвтварвтп.
David Boder: ре?
Sigmund Reich: фшаси, фщеи аеетчвтварвтп. щфтитш, айж - жтртп о’ а варх рали втееаргтши бйж о’ жтртп втчеотп ц’ а че [?], аеп втчеотп гаши айп а гтшу [гашу]... [аеочмаш?] аеп о’аи втжави аж - аж о’айж втишафп аейфп еетв, тфтс а щех-фамйцтс. [Schutzpolizei]
David Boder: [In English] Yes?
Sigmund Reich: [In Yiddish]феп шейип - тфтс - гтн шейип-чшййх - л’втгтрч рйщи втрей ееас с’айж втеетп... аеп [тш] ‘аи аергж ашййрвтфйши цен бйшвтш-оййситш - гаши айж тс втеетп... ‘аи о’ - ‘аи о’ втжави аж аергж жтртп о’ фашмейшп втварвтп феп а ишарсфаши, аеп аергжтш ишарсфаши гашу вййп бйж щееййх ашййп.
David Boder: Oh! ре? еей ееййи жйри тх втеетжп феп гтш щееййх?
Sigmund Reich: с’втеетп дергтши 50 чймаотитш.
David Boder: ре? ... [аеочмаш?] жа, даи оае... [аеочмаш?] ц’ гй с.с.? [S.S.]
Sigmund Reich: гаши, чййп с.с. [S.S.]
David Boder: ре?
Sigmund Reich: а лйфт [chyba (Polish for maybe; probably)] ажамлт [ажтмлт] - а лйфт гй ееас жтртп щейп ажейрт - амт втеетп аейфп фшари. лйфт ажамлт ееас ‘абп щейп рйщи втчари - eh - вййтп аейфп фшари.
David Boder: ... [аеочмаш?] шейип-чшййх?
Sigmund Reich: ... [аеочмаш?]. аергж жтртп втварвтп аейфп еетв, ‘аи тш аергж втишафп.
David Boder: йа?
Sigmund Reich: аеп тш ‘аи - ‘аи - ‘аи аергж ашййрвтфйши цен бйшвтш-оййситш. тш ‘аи втжави аж тш ‘аи аергж втишафп аейфп еетв, аеп аергж ‘абп втжави г’ бйшвтш-оййситш аж аергж ‘абп аейсвтфагтши г’ шейип-чшййх бйж щееййх ашййп.
David Boder: [аеочмаИш]
Sigmund Reich: ре - ‘аи о’ аергж - ‘аи о’ аергж... тш айж тфтс фашойщи втееашп - ‘аи тш аергж втвмййби [втвмейби] гас ееаши аййп.
David Boder: йа. ре, даи тш... [аеочмаш?]
Sigmund Reich: тш ‘аи аергж аеетч[...?] ... иачт втвтбп а бйсм жефт [жеф] гаши... аргтшт... аеп тш ‘аи аергж... [аеочмаш?] бйж цен - бйж ц’ бйж цен еетв ееас фйши айп щееййх ашййп.
David Boder: йа?
Sigmund Reich: ‘аи втжави гтн жтмртш, аж тш жам аергж мажп вййтп айп г’ еетв, фаш аергж ‘абп о’ аейсвтфагтши г’ шейип-чшййх бйж щееййх ашййп ц’ вййп.
David Boder: ре?
Sigmund Reich: ре, аергж жтртп втварвтп ойип еетв. жтртп о’ арвтчеотп рак цеейй [...?], ‘абп о’ втееами гаши ртлийчп, абтш г’ бйшвтш-оййситш ‘аи рйщи втееами. втеетп а вшейстш шщт, гтш бйшвтш-оййситш...
David Boder: Alright. ееас даи айш втееами жавп? [аеочмаш?]
Sigmund Reich: [тш д]'’аи втжави [тш] ‘аи а ск... еей тс чеои ап... [аеочмаш?]
David Boder: [In English] Also...this is Spool 74, continuation of 73, Sigmund Reich, the interviewee.
David Boder: [In Yiddish] амжа. жййи тх ашййрвтчеотп це ап аргтш щиаи.
Sigmund Reich: йа.
David Boder: аеп тх даи втчеотп це гтш бйшвтш-оййситш, аеп айш ‘аи втжави аж айш жййи айци арвтфагтши фертн шейип-чшййх?
David Boder: But тш даи рйщи втфшави [втфштви] чййп фафйшп, чййп вашрйщи?
Sigmund Reich: [тш] ‘аи вашрйщи втфштви.
David Boder: еетп айж тс втеетжп - айп 45’ щейп?
Sigmund Reich: айп 45’.
David Boder: йа. ре?
Sigmund Reich: аеп аергж жтртп о’... щфтитш жтртп о’ втчеотп айп а цееййи щитим ашййп.
David Boder: йа?
Sigmund Reich: ... айп а цееййи щитим ашййп, аеп гаши ‘аи о’... ‘аи о’ аейк... [аеочмаш?] абтш г’ бйшвтш-оййситш ‘аи аейк рйщи втмажи. ‘аи втжави аж тш ‘аи а фмак фаш оймйитш, с’айж рйщи - ‘аи тш рйщи чййп фмак фаш аергж.
Sigmund Reich: ... жтртп о’ втварвтп ееййитш - о’аи рйщи втдаи чййп бшйшд, аеп о’аи арвтишафп гаши тфтс а фейтш ееас даи вташбти. тш айж втеетп аййртш - тш айж втеетп аййртш аш[....?] феп гй бап арвтщитмит.
David Boder: йа?
Sigmund Reich: аергж жтртп о’ цевтвартп аеп втбтип - втбтип еетвп - еетвп бартлийчп айп а щиам. ‘аи тш втжави аж гаши айж га а чмййп щитмтлм еее тш дами тфтс а бйсм бмтитш, ееас тш гашу фаш аеритшцебтип гй бдоеъ аеп аейк гй фтшг.
David Boder: бмтитш?
Sigmund Reich: бмтитш, бмтитш.
David Boder: бмтитш, йа?
Sigmund Reich: аеп - аеп с’айж жййтш чмййп, аеп амт отрищп - амт оаот[?] еети рйщи ашййп... [аеочмаш?]. рййп, фмах еети щейп жййп втрев... [аеочмаш?].
David Boder: абтш, даи тш втфштви еетш айш жййи?
Sigmund Reich: тш ‘аи втфштви, ‘аи о’ айн втжави аж г’ шейип-чшййх - ‘аи о’ айн втжави аж г’ шейип-чшййх ‘аи аергж аейсвтфагтши феп щееййх.
David Boder: ре?
Sigmund Reich: тш ‘аи - тш ‘аи аергж ашййрвтмажи. тш ‘аи аергж щфтитш афйме втбштрви а бйсм оймк, аеп айп... айп гтш фшй ‘абп о’ втееейш втееашп аж тш айж а бап... [аеочмаш?]. ‘абп о’ аергж айн втфштви ц’ тш чап рйщи ажей о’ жамп чартп фашп бйж ц’ г’ щееййцтш вштртх. ‘аи тш втжави йа, тх чартп аейк оалп - втжави аж о’жамп - ан гтн 7 Uhr [?] - айк чап рйщи втрей жавп еетмлт цййи - жамп о’ чеотп аейу г’ бап аеп о’ти ашейсвййп аейу гтш цев.
Sigmund Reich: ажей жтртп о’ - ‘абп о’ аейфвтщиартп, жйк арвтееащп, аеп гтп втвтсп тфтс.
David Boder: ееастшт - ееас фаш а чмййгтш дабп втишавп?
Sigmund Reich: айк ‘аб втдаи цйееймтп, раш аргтшт ‘абп втдаи гас...
David Boder: втщишййфит чмййгерв. ре?
Sigmund Reich: втщишййфит чмййгерв.
David Boder: ре?
Sigmund Reich: аеп... аеп аергж жтртп щфти втчеотп цен бап дау гашип, аеп жтртп цевтчеотп цен бап, аеп втееаши бйж гтш цев чеои. гтш цев айж втчеотп, аергж ‘абп о’ ашейфвтжйцп аейфп...
David Boder: ап гй бймти?
Sigmund Reich: тш ‘аи... ап гй бймтип. тш ‘аи щейп ажей бажашви аж о’ жам фашп ап чййп бймтип. щфтитш жтртп о’ втфашп бйж...
David Boder: еетш айж втеетп - гтш сиацйарс-фйштш?
Sigmund Reich: рййп. тш айж втеетп а - гас айж втеетп а чмййрт сиацйап, аеп тш айж гаши втеетп ап аййрвтщитмитш.
David Boder: аЗдаЗ. ре?
Sigmund Reich: аеп еетп о’ - еетп о’ щейп аейу г’ - аейфп цев, жтртп о’ втфашп...
David Boder: втеетжп а гййищ?
Sigmund Reich: йа.
David Boder: [аеочмаИш]
Sigmund Reich: аеп о’айж втфашп бйж - бйж ч’ Bludenz [/тсишййкAustria].гаши жтртп о’ арвтщийвп аеп о’айж цевтварвтп - о’айж вмййк втеетп аейу г’ гййищ фамйцйй, аеп о’аи втжави аж о’жам ойк втбп а фафйш а’ ойи о’жам чартп ееййитш фашп бйж айп г’ щееййцтш вштртх ашййп. ‘аи тш втжави ажей: а фафйш чап айк трч рйщи вт[б]п... рак... л’тм трч вт[б]п аейу а ееййитш... еетп айк ‘тм ееййитш фашп.
David Boder: йа?
Sigmund Reich: ре...
David Boder: тш чтп аййк втбп фаш а бймти.
Sigmund Reich: аейу а бймти. абтш а фафйш аж... аж о’жйри бафшййи втееашп... аж... жтртп о’ бафшййи втееашп, агтш аж аергж жамп о’ вййтп, ‘аи тш рйщи втчари аергж вт[б]п.
David Boder: даи Sie айн втжави аж айш жййи дтфимйрвтп?
Sigmund Reich: йа. аергж ‘абп айн втжави...
David Boder: Das war гтш бйшвтш-оййситш, йа?
Sigmund Reich: с’втеетп айп Bludenz. гас айж рйщи втеетп бйшвтш-оййситш.
David Boder: а фамйцйй?
Sigmund Reich: а фамйцйй айж гас втеетжп.
David Boder: дн.
Sigmund Reich: а гййищ фамйцйй. щфтитш, ‘аи тш аергж втдййси тшвтх вййтп еее о’аи жйк втгашфи дашп [?] [Germ. “hцren”] гас втми. втварвтп дашп [?] гас втми, аеп щфтитш втварвтп...
David Boder: а еее дашп [?] втми?
Sigmund Reich: тфтс гаши а аои втеетп. ‘аи тш аергж гаши адйрвтщйчи.
David Boder: ре?
Sigmund Reich: аеп о’аи гаши бачеотп гас втми, аеп о’айж втварвтп чейфп бймти. втварвтп чейфп бймти... [аеочмаш?] айж гтш цев втварвтп. рййп а’жййвтш жтртп о’ втчеотп цен бап дау гаши, аеп о’...
David Boder: аеп айш даи рйи оеша втдаи? айш даи аеетчвт... [аеочмаш?]
Sigmund Reich: ... [аеочмаш?] о’аи бтдейфи аййрвтщитми [?] ... аж с’еети втмервтп, еети втмервтп, ‘ти рйщи втмервтп, ‘ти рйщи втмервтп.
David Boder: ре?
Sigmund Reich: аеп рййп а’жййвтш... жтртп о’ ашййрвтвартп айп маси ееавартп, аеп щфтитш, тфтс а цййи цтрт айж г’ цев аеетчвтфашп. ажей, жтртп о’ втеетп айп... айп Feldkirch.
David Boder: Feld-...
Sigmund Reich: Feldkirch. гас айж ртбп г’ щееййцт вштртх. гаши, даи о’ щейп втеееси... дабп о’ втеееси аж о’ оеж ееашип бйж г’ фшй. айп г’ фшй жтртп о’ - дабп о’ втееаши. жтртп о’... ‘абп о’ втееами цевййтп ц’ г’ вштртх. с’втеетп...
David Boder: ... чййп S.S. айж рйи втеетп?
Sigmund Reich: рййп, бйй г’ вштртх айж втщиартп гтш Wehrmacht.
David Boder: ре?
Sigmund Reich: амжа, ‘абп о’ втжтп о’ чап рйщи цевййтп. абп о’ втжтп гаши тфтс а - а дейлтш бааоитш. ‘абп о’ айн втбтип тш жам аергж мажп ашейсвййтп о’жам чартп агешлвййтп, о’ жтртп айп варцп арвтщееали, аеп аергж - аергж ееймп - аергж ееймп бмейж вййтп айп а щфйиам ашййп...
Sigmund Reich: [аеочмаш?] шейип-чшййх. аергж ‘абп о’ аейсвтфагтши. амжа, [т]ш ‘аи втжави тш еети аергж амтс [амх] гтшмййгйчп. о’аи втдаи а фаш чашиафм бйй жйк, ‘абп о’ афйме гашип втчали жйй.
David Boder: йа?
Sigmund Reich: аеп гас айж втеетп аергжтш фшйщийч аеп аергжтш ойиав. щфтитш, ‘абп о’ - ‘абп жйй арвтдейбп це щиефп це г’ вштртх. ‘абп о’ втжтп - ‘абп жйй отрищп жйк арвтдейбп це щиефп це г’ вштртх. аеп о’аи айп варцп рйщи агешлвтмажи ч’ ск отрищп. йтгп иав а фаш оап. амжа...
David Boder: гййищйщтш аейк?
Sigmund Reich: рййп, рййп. с’жтртп втеетп а оййсип аейсмтргтш.
David Boder: ре?
Sigmund Reich: аеп ... аеп [г’ еетв] [?] жйй щиефп жйк... аергж дабп втжтп аж аергж чартп рйщи арчеотп, ‘абп о’ аергж аейк арвтдейбп ц’ щиефп. о’аи жйк цевтщиефи ц’ г’ гшаип, айк бйп щейп втеетп айп варцп щееак, аеп о’аи - о’аи арвтдейбп ц’ щшййтп а[ж] о’ гашу дйму. аеп ажей айж цевтчеотп а гййищ - а Wachmann, ‘аи тш...
David Boder: а гййищ агтш а щееййцтш?
Sigmund Reich: а гййищ, а гййищ, а гййищ. о’аи айн втжави аж аергж ееймп о’ бмейж - бмейж айп щфйиам ашййрвййтп, ееййм о’ жтртп айп варцп арвтщееалп [?]. тш ‘аи втжави тш [ее]ти ваш втчари оалп. ‘аи тш цевтшефп г’ щееййцтш фасип [Posten].
David Boder: йа.
Sigmund Reich: г’ щееййцтш фасип ‘аи втееами цешефп гтн - гтн...
David Boder: афйцйш?
Sigmund Reich: афйцйш. аеп о’аи айн втжави аергж ееймп бмейж вййтп айп щфйиам ашййп, ееййм о’жтртп айп варцп арвтщееали. ‘аи тш аергж втдййсп бамг агешлфашп. гаши... жтртп о’ гаши тшвтх бйй мйлитрщиййп [Lichtenstein] втеетп.
David Boder: йа?
Sigmund Reich: аеп гаши даи о’... ‘аи о’... ‘аи о’ аергж бамг втвт[б]п бйсчеейип гаши ц’ тсп, чаеет ц’ ишйрчп - гй мййлсит жак ееас о’аи - о’аи втчари тсп. аеп о’аи бамг гаши... айж аейфвтчеотп а втеейстш гачиаш. л’аб фашвтсп еей тш ‘аи втдййсп, аеп...
David Boder: а ййг?
Sigmund Reich: а ййг, а ййг. о’даи ойи айн аейк втштги. с’айж гаши втеетп афйме жщешрамйсип феп аотшйчт. аеп гали жй ойш с’айж аейлти втеетп афйме а ййгйщт жщешрамйсийп.
David Boder: йа?
Sigmund Reich: втрей, чап айк рйщи жавп. щфтитш, ‘аи о’ аергж втреотп аейу а аейиа, аеп о’аи аергж адйрвтфйши ч’ Buchs щфйиам ашййп.
David Boder: дн.
Sigmund Reich: гаши жтртп о’ втеетп а цеейй ееалп. о’аи аергж жййтш веи бадаргми. аеп о’аи рйщи втвтсп ч’ бшейи, фаш г’ гачиаш даи аергж фашбаип. о’аи бмейж втвтсп бйсчеейип аеп мййлит жалп. щфтитш, жтртп о’ щейп втеетп бтс... дейм [дййм] аеп о’аи втчшйвп гашип а фаш ариетлх, аеп о’аи втчшйвп аейлти щейп бшейи...
David Boder: ариетлх, гас дййси чмййгтш - йа?
Sigmund Reich: йа. цйееймйщт чмййгтш.
David Boder: ре?
Sigmund Reich: аеп гаши, рак гй цеейй ееалп, жтртп о’ втчеотп га айп щееййх, айртн чашарийп мавтш, Gattikon [?].
David Boder: [In German] Was?
Sigmund Reich: Gattikon [?].
David Boder: Ja?
Sigmund Reich: [In Yiddish] а чашарийп мавтш.
David Boder: айп ееас фаш а мавтш?
Sigmund Reich: а чееашарийртш.
David Boder: а чееашарийп мавтш. йа. ре?
Sigmund Reich: гшйй ееалп ‘аи о’ втоежи гаши бмййбп. айп гтн мавтш айж втеетп жййтш щмтли.
David Boder: щмтли?
Sigmund Reich: жййтш щмтли.
David Boder: фаш ееас?
Sigmund Reich: тшщирс, тсп айж рйщи веи втеетп.
David Boder: йа.
Sigmund Reich: цееййирс, айж втеетп жййтш ееййрйч.
David Boder: [In German] Was?
Sigmund Reich: [In Yiddish] цееййирс, айж втеетп жййтш ееййрйч.
David Boder: йа.
Sigmund Reich: аеп гаши ‘аи о’ втчали бмейж чашиафм.
David Boder: йа?
Sigmund Reich: рйщи отш. ч’ фмййщ даи о’ - айж айбтш дейфи рйщи втеетп, ‘абп о’ - ‘абп о’ аййрвтвтсп... о’аи раш втмтби феп чашиафм аеп гас фйфим бшейи ееас о’аи втчшйвп.
David Boder: Sind Sie айп щееййцп чашарийп?
Sigmund Reich: йа.
David Boder: ре?
Sigmund Reich: аеп гаши...
David Boder: еей фйм отрищп жййртп гаши втеетп?
Sigmund Reich: гаши айж втеетп тфтс а дергтши оап.
David Boder: йа.
Sigmund Reich: абтш с’жтртп аейлти втеетп... амт жтртп втеетп феп чарцтришацйап [мавтшп] аеп жйй жтртп втеетп феп аргтшт.
Sigmund Reich: аеп аергж - аергж жтртп гаши втеетп гшйй ееалп. рак гй гшйй ееалп, жтртп о’ втчеотп ч’ Waedenswil, аеп...
David Boder: еее?
Sigmund Reich: ч’ Waedenswil.
David Boder: Waedenswil?
Sigmund Reich: Waedenswil.
David Boder: йа?
Sigmund Reich: гаши - гаши жтртп о’ аейк втеетп тфтс а цеейй ееалп. айж втчеотп тфтс а гачиаш, Emma феп щееййх аеп [жй] даи аергж ашейсвтреотп, фаш аергж ‘абп втееами вййтп айп а штмйвйтжп мавтш еее отп тси лщш.
David Boder: йа.
Sigmund Reich: амжа, о’аи аергж аейсвтреотп аеп о’аи аергж втщйчи ч’ Attenberg [?]. аеп айп Attenberg [?] айж аергж втеетп жййтш веи.
David Boder: айж рйщи втеетп жййтш веи?
Sigmund Reich: йа. с’айж втеетп жййтш веи гаши.
David Boder: Was [pronounced “vas”] dis [this] айп а ййгйщтш, а лщштш мавтш?
Sigmund Reich: йа.
David Boder: ре?
Sigmund Reich: аеп о’аи гаши втмтшри а бйсм, аеп о’аи вташбти а бйсм. тфтс - йтгт жтчс ееалп жтртп о’ втфашп аейу Urlaub гшйй, фйш иав.
David Boder: еее жйри айш втфашп аейу Urlaub?
Sigmund Reich: аеп... айк... еетп аергж жтртп втфашп ч’ Waedenswil, ‘аи о’ аергж втщйчи ч’ Zurich аейу гтн тшщип щбъ, жтртп о’ гаши втеетп. ‘аи о’ ойк цевтиййми фаш а фшей, бйп айк гаши щиабйм втфашп.
David Boder: це а фаоймйт?
Sigmund Reich: йа. фаш а фаоймйт.
David Boder: ре?
Sigmund Reich: бйп айк гаши втфашп це г’ фаоймйт йтгт жтчс ееалп.
David Boder: йа?
Sigmund Reich: аеп гаши, щфтитш, феп - ‘аи жйк втвшйргт[ш]и айп Morcote [?] а аши - а дййн феп бмейж гй йервт ееас жтртп феп чарцтришацйарс-мавт[ш]. жтртп о’ гаши адйрвтфашп. гаши, жтртп о’ втеетп 3 оараи. гас айж втеетп айп [аеочмаш?] бйй Lugano [?]. жййтш щййп - жййтш щййрт[ш] втври гаши. дййс - гаши айж а жййтш ееашотш чмйоаи. аеп о’аи рйщи ч’ ск вташбти. айк даб - айк даб вташбти бййн дейж [аеочмаш?]. айк даб бмейж [гт]н дейж айбтшвтоали.
David Boder: гй [Germ. pronunciation] was?
Sigmund Reich: дейж, гас дейж.
David Boder: ... гй втбййгт?
Sigmund Reich: ... гй втбййгт...
David Boder: йа.
Sigmund Reich: о’аи тс втоали [?]. аеп о’аи гаши втмтшри. а дамбп иав ‘аи от’ втмтшри...
David Boder: ееас даи отп втмтшри - дтбштйщ?
Sigmund Reich: дтб... рйщи ч’ дтбштйщ, раш зеощ, шщ”‘, воша.
David Boder: [In English] Oh yes, I mean a...
Sigmund Reich: [In Yiddish] йа.
David Boder: ... а ййгйщт [аеочмаш?] ... йа, ре? Was гашип а шбй?
Sigmund Reich: рййп, гаши айж рйщи втеетп ч’ шбй. бйй Attenberg [аеочмаш?] айж бмейж втеетп а шбй.
David Boder: ре.
Sigmund Reich: шб йерд феп щееййх.
David Boder: йа.
Sigmund Reich: тш айж айци айп цйшйк [Zurich].
Sigmund Reich: айп Morcote [?] гас айж втеетп тфтс еей гшйй-фйш оараи, аеп щфтитш жтртп о’ втчеотп ч’ Genf аейу - аейу г’ ORT щем.
David Boder: це гтш ORT щемт?
Sigmund Reich: йа.
David Boder: Und jetzt ееейри Ihr еее?
Sigmund Reich: айци ееейртп wir аеу гтш Avenue de Champel [?].
David Boder: гас дййси, а дййн фаш гй йервт аеп гй...
Sigmund Reich: йа, гас айж фшйееаи. с’айж рйщи ч’ дййн, с’айж фшйееаи. аергж...
David Boder: еей фйм жтртп гаши?
Sigmund Reich: жтртп гаши тфтс 20 оап.
David Boder: аеп еее тси айш?
Sigmund Reich: гаши тсп wir.
David Boder: аЗдаЗ. аеп жави ойш, ееас мтшри отп?
Sigmund Reich: от мтшри гаши цеейй-гшйй оам айп ееак - мтшри отп зеощ, шщ”‘.
David Boder: йа?
Sigmund Reich: от’ мтшри... от’ мтшри гаши дтбштйщ, мтшри от’. от’ мтшри...
David Boder: жав ойш, ееас мтшртп Sie hier?
Sigmund Reich: Hier... Hier, аейу а - аейу а отларйщп - а отларйщп Beruf.
David Boder: аеп еей марв еети тх [?] ртотп тс цен аейсмтшртп?
Sigmund Reich: еей марв це бмййбп [?], еетм айк бмййбп.
David Boder: йа. аеп гтп, ееас еетмп Sie иетп?
Sigmund Reich: аеп гап, дау айк аж айк чап фашп ч’ ашх.
David Boder: [In English] To where?
Sigmund Reich: [In Yiddish] ч’ ашх.
David Boder: [In English] Where is that?
Sigmund Reich: [In Yiddish] ашх йщшам.
David Boder: [In German] Nach Palestine willen Sie gehen?
Sigmund Reich: [In Yiddish] йа.
David Boder: ре, еее даи айш Verwandte айп ашх йщшам?
Sigmund Reich: айп ашх йщшам даб айк рйщи ч’ Verwandte.
David Boder: ре, даи айш Verwandte айп аотшйчт?
Sigmund Reich: айк ееййс оййп арчм даи гаши тфтс а чежйрт, варх ееййи. феп ойш айж жй варх ееййи. айк - айк щшййб айш рйщи аеп жй щшййби ойш [рйщи]...
David Boder: [аеочмаИш]
Sigmund Reich: рЦп.
David Boder: дн.
Sigmund Reich: раш гтн аййртн арчм ееас айк даб айп бтмвйт [Belgium].
David Boder: айп бтмвйт. щшййби айш жйк ойи айн?
Sigmund Reich: йа. тш айж айци га - га айп гтш щееййх, фаш тш айж аейк га гшйй йаш [цежаотп ойи ойш] [?] айп чарцтришацйарс-мавтш [Konzentrationslager].
David Boder: тш айж айп а чарцтришацйарс... [Konzentrations...] жа, ееас иеи тш айци айп гтш щееййх?
Sigmund Reich: айци, айп гтш щееййх, айж тш втчеотп erholen. тш айж мервтп чшарч.
David Boder: аЗд.
Sigmund Reich: аеп айци еетши тш щейп а ск бтстш еей фшйтш.
David Boder: айци [?], чтп айш [г]тшцйймп еетмлт цййип даи айш втдаи гй щмтлитси [щмтлсит] айп чарцтришацйарс-мавтш? [Konzentrationslager]
Sigmund Reich: гй щмтлсит айж втеетп айп Kamenz.
David Boder: йа?
Sigmund Reich: דארט, זענען מ’ געווען א שיין פאר מאנאט. דארט, ערשטנס, עסן איז זייער שלעכט געווען. די באהאנדלונג, אויך, איז געווען זייער שלעכט. די... איבער הויפט... די מענטשן וואס זענען געווען אין קאנצענטראציאנס-לאגער, [Konzentrationslager] די Häftlinge אליין, די גויים זענען געווען גרויסע רשעים. [זיי] האבן נישט געקאנט אויפקוקן אויף ק’ ייד. און [א]חוץ דעם, די וואכער [וועכטער] זענען אלע געווען אונגערישע. די אונגערישע וואכער זענען געווען זייער - זייער שלעכט.
David Boder: [In German] Das war ungarische S.S.?
Sigmund Reich: S.S.
David Boder: Ja?
Sigmund Reich: [In Yiddish] ... [аеочмаш?] втееашп втоамгп амс - eh -амс - гййищп - амс гййищп [?]. аеп жйй ‘абп аергж баееали. йтгп оам айп г’ фшй жтртп о’ ашейсвтварвтп ажей еей с’даи оашвп арвтдейбп тфтс ц’ иетп, ‘аи о’ аейфвтщиартп, аеп о’аи аергж втфйши ц’ г’ ашбти, аеп ажей, еетп с’айж тфтс фйрситш втееашп, ‘аи о’ щейп - ‘аи о’ аергж цешйчвтфйши [noise/interruption during recording session/ап айбтшшййс бщтъ гтш штчашгйшерв ] [аеочмаш?].
David Boder: [In English] Yes, in Kamenz.
Sigmund Reich: [In Yiddish]гаши, гй ееалтш жтртп втеетп аервтштш, аеп жйй ‘абп аергж жййтш щмтли бадаргми. аеп - аеп жйй ‘абп аергж втщмавп ойи гй втеетшп. жйй ‘абп втщмавп йтгтш аййртн. аеп йтгп жерийч - с’втчеотп йтгп жерийч, ‘аи о’ втоали вйорасийч айп г’ фшй.
David Boder: ееас was [pron. as “vas”] гас?
Sigmund Reich: гас - гас дййси - о’аи втдййсп чрйтп аеп жйцп. гй отрищп ееас дабп рйщи втдаи ч’ лз - о’аи втгарчи ваи - о’аи - тс чеои а жерийч, о’аи втчари жйк аршетп. ... [аеочмаш?] ашейсвт... [аеочмаш?], от’ жам оалп вйорасийч. аеп иаотш тотцтш даи тс рйщи веи втоали, ‘аи от’ - ‘аи от’ - ‘аи от’ втщмавп гтн оап. аеп ажей - чейн даи отп гаши [?] ... феп арфарв даи отп втдаи аейу фйш оап а бшейи. а бшейи - а бшейи даи втдаи тфтсс а чйма - а чйма 02. [аеочмаш?] аеп аейу [аеочмаш?] ... с’айж втеетп жййтш щмтли, ‘аи от’ втвт[б]п аейу али оап ажа бшейи. Sogar, щфтитш, аейу - аейу цтп оап.
David Boder: аеп еей даи отп тс цтиййми?
Sigmund Reich: о’аи - о’аи аергж втвт[б]п а варх бшейи.
David Boder: дн.
Sigmund Reich: аеп о’аи втдййсп тс ц’ цтийймп.
David Boder: ееас фаш а иаие [tattoo] даи айш hier?
Sigmund Reich: гас - гас - гас айж втееашп айп феймп втоали.
David Boder: еетш даи тс втоали?
Sigmund Reich: айп Mielec. гас дабп гй гййищт [гййищйщт] S.S. втоали. йтгтш аййртш bevor ... bevor ... Mielec ... bevor с’айж втеетп а цйееймп-мавтш, аеп щфтитш айж втееашп [аеочмаш?] аейс айп а чацти, ‘аи о’ йтгтш аййртн втоали а KL аейу г’ дари.
David Boder: ееас айж гас - ееас оййри гас, KL?
Sigmund Reich: KL дййси чарцтришацйарс-мавтш. [Konzentrationslager]
David Boder: Oh! KL. аеп - аеп гй гййищп дабп тс це аййк втоали?
Sigmund Reich: йа, гй гййищп.
David Boder: жйй дабп рйщи вт...